[Música]
se ha acostumbrado al frío y a la falta
de luz tras casi siete años en Suecia
pero el recuerdo de su país natal lo
asaltó recientemente en su vida
ankara reclama la extradición de este
periodista próximo al movimiento
en varias ocasiones en Turquía para
alivio de violen el tribunal
constitucional sueco rechazó esta
petición a finales de diciembre
el régimen de erdogan no va a Rendirse
así nomás creo que seguirán intentando
nuevos métodos nuevas tácticas para
intimidarme
en Suecia este periodista es el enemigo
número uno del presidente Turco en
recientes conversaciones con el Primer
Ministro sueco receta allí perdogan
ha exigido personalmente su extradición
está en una lista de perfiles que
Turquía quiere recuperar a cambio ankara
Se compromete a levantar su veto a la
entrada de Suecia y Finlandia en la otan
un chantaje peligroso según el
periodista
las autoridades occidentales Siguen sin
comprender del todo la verdadera
naturaleza del despotismo de erdogan
se imagina que se utilizará un
periodista como moneda de cambio en una
cuestión tan geopolítica como la
pertenencia de la otan
hay una gran desproporción en todo esto
a principios de diciembre estocolmo
deportó a un ciudadano Turco
había sido condenado en Turquía por
pertenencia a la pkka organización
considerada terrorista por ankara desde
entonces esta mujer kurda teme mucho por
su marido que también está amenazado de
expulsión
la ex periodista cree que ankara la
tiene en la mira a través de él como
mishin tiene nacionalidad sueca no puede
ser deportada ni extraditada hoy se
reúne con este periodista sueco para
hablar de su caso teme que Suecia acabe
doblegándose ante el presidente Turco
mi marido y yo ya no nos sentimos
seguros en Suecia pregunta a las
autoridades quería saber más sobre lo
que se me acusa quería pruebas pero no
me contestaron
estas personas tenían la sensación de
seguridad de que este país era una
especie de Refugio seguro para
refugiados políticos o disidentes
ahora consideran que esta seguridad no
es tan sólida como antes para este otro
periodista objetivo de la prensa próximo
al gobierno de Turquía se trata de mucho
más que una impresión
he aquí el título que me describe como
interlocutor del traidor y este es mi
dirección han publicado Mi dirección
varios de sus colegas han sido agredidos
en Suecia uno de ellos violentamente
se trata de un caso muy grave permaneció
en cuidados intensivos durante varias
semanas
estuvo a punto de morir en un atentado
patrocinado por el Ministerio del
interior Turco creemos que sí y hay
varios indicios de ello en la sede de la
Organización de defensa de los Derechos
Humanos la cuestión es hasta dónde
Llegará el gobierno para permitir que
Suecia se incorpore a la alianza
atlántica durante el brevísimo debate
que mantuvimos en Suecia en primavera en
torno a la entrada en la otan lo que
plantearon claramente los políticos fue
que era importante entrar en la otan
para proteger nuestra democracia y
valores como el estado de derecho y de
los Derechos Humanos
pero lo que vemos hoy es que son
precisamente estos valores los que se
están viendo comprometidos
Suecia tiene una larga tradición de
aceptación de refugiados políticos en el
parlamento sueco cinco diputados son de
origen kurdo amenezca cadáver era
miembro del hemiciclo anterior en Suecia
desde hace casi 30 años este antiguo pez
merga de origen kurdo iraní teme el giro
que puedan tomar las cosas sobre todo
desde la llegada de otoño de un nuevo
gobierno apoyado por la extrema derecha
durante más de 200 años hemos sido
dignos de la paz y los Derechos Humanos
pero hoy están al descubierto frente a
erdogan
ya sea el anterior gobierno
socialdemócrata
o el actual de derechas
están haciendo daño a nuestro hermoso
país que ha sido muy importante para
nosotros los refugiados
además de la cuestión del ingreso en la
otan la coalición gobernante ha
prometido una política migratoria más
estricta en el país
[Música]